hey guys this is andrew for
changingcensus.com so i've been working
as a professional chatter for the past
six years in hong kong
and i've decided to make a youtube
channel because guys i want to pass the
knowledge i want to explain to you all
the different tools and techniques that
pro traders are using
that i use that work for me and most
importantly guys i want to explain to
you how to use it yourself because it's
not that complicated
so if you want to know about all this
stuff and basically how to make money on
the market you guys are in the right
place
so today i want to make an analysis on
option open interest in gamestop
and amc let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so if you go on yahoo
finance and
you type gamestop you can find the
option chains and you can find depending
on the maturity
all the options the open interest of the
options so the big maturities are for
example
16 of april so it's in three weeks and
here you have the number of open
interest
you know this column all right so i
computed all these data so for example
you can see
that for the 200 strike
you have 3 000 open interest i'm gonna
explain to you guys how to understand
this data and what is very interesting
guys is look at the 800
you have 16 000 options
like open interest in options so of
course it's called
options so guys i take all this data
and look what i do with it so i
basically compute
for every strike and let's take
for example 16 of april first as a
maturity
and here guys i have a chart that is
basically giving me
depending on the strike so 100 200 so
right now gamestop is here
300 400 you can see the open interest
so you can do the calls or the puts but
what is interesting is actually to have
the
sum of it so this is the sum of it so
when you look at this
what do you see you see that the 200
strike there is a lot of open interest
what does it mean it means
that retail investors they are buying
call and put options
so here you don't know if it's a call or
put but for example for the 300 400 we
know it's called
options we know that retail investors
actually buying it
and who is selling it it's market makers
some hedge funds
some banks some professionals all right
so
those professionals they are left with
the short position
that is going against a retail investor
and usually the kind of thing
you see is that around the money so
around 200 you have the more
open interest but for gamestop the thing
is very different guys
look at how big are the open interest
for the very out of the money call
options on the 400
500 you know all these maturities so
this is only for april
you have a lot of open interest and the
crazy thing
is the insane amount of
call options that people about on the
800
strike so guys once again this number is
16 000 as you can see here so this data
i got it from here you can see 16
697 and this is for the april maturity
and i can retrieve this data and you can
use as well july
you know and you have a pattern guys is
that for the 800 you always have
something around 16 000 so i'm gonna
explain to you guys
how to convert this into uh notional
and to help you understand what is going
to happen if gamestop is going higher
so first i d i do this for all the
maturity so i'll do this for
april if i do this for may it looks like
this
so on the main maturity you have a lot
of 400 450
you don't have the 800 and if i do on
the july maturity so it's
three months look what i have again
this crazy amount of cool options on the
upside but guys it's really really
insane
so what i did is that i sum it up all
right
i take the sum of all of them and
i decided to compute it as a notional
so to compute it as a notional i'm not
sure you're very interested into this
but you basically
just multiply the open interest by the
value
of uh the stock so here say 130
and by the multiplier which is 100 and
this is giving you
a notional if i take the sum of all the
notionals of all the strikes
i come up with this chart all right
so let me put it in out of color
so i come up with this chart all right
guys so look at this
i computed just a notional
open interest so this means that if the
price
goes higher stay with me i know this is
not so easy to understand guys this is a
pro trader
approach this is what i would do you
know at work if i need to analyze
something i would look at the open
interest
and i would try to understand what are
the flows what are the dynamics of the
flows on the upside and here i know that
if gamestop
so gamestop is here right now if
gamestop goes higher
all this uh open interest is basically
some short
gamma position data left to
professionals and those professionals
they're basically gonna have
a short delta uh arriving on
their position that they would need to
cover so either they increase the short
interest or they are just buying
so and in terms of nationals guys we
arrive
the national open interest at 2 at
800 guys is more than 2 billion
us dollar and if i sum up all the upside
so if i sum up everything that is above
let's say
200 i have
five billion guys of uh
open interest national so this is huge
this is insane i've never seen something
like this
all right so this is telling me that if
the price action
is going higher market makers
hedge funds are gonna become
increasingly short
so this is what is a gamma squeeze
because this open interest is actually
some gamma position so i wanted to show
you this guys and i want to show you
something else
i want to do the same thing for amc guys
so if i do the same thing for amc
i have here so i do the same thing guys
so the strikes are different we have 10
20 30 and i check the different
maturities so you can see that we don't
have this phenomenon we have
for example the maximum open interest is
around the money which is
normal so people so if i check may
may i don't have anything as well and if
i take june
oh here i have something at the 40 level
so there are some people that bought a
lot of
40 calls so you're gonna have a bit the
same phenomenon
but once again guys look at the
difference gamestop
what is happening is insane so if you
are wondering which stock
might show squeeze or gamma squeeze the
answer is gamestop and i just explained
to you
how the options actually gonna affect
the price action
so guys if you enjoyed this video please
let me know and click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i'll see you
guys